Britain builds more satellites than
anywhere outside California but in the
past they've had to ship them abroad as
far as New Zealand now they've got a
Spaceport just down the road
this is Cosmic girl once a passenger jet
now a rocket launch pad it will take off
from Newquay airport with a 21 meter
rocket slung under its wing the first
mission to put satellites into orbit
from UK soil
in a previous life this jumbo jet flew
two and a half million passengers across
the Atlantic the seats have now been
stripped out and the upper deck has been
turned into Mission Control
after taking off from new key Cosmic
girl will head to the Drop Zone off
Island South Coast she'll do laps around
What's called the racetrack while
Engineers carry out final checks then at
35 000 feet the rocket will release via
its engines and accelerate to 8 000
miles an hour past Portugal and into
space
foreign
is already one of the biggest Builders
of satellites but the government says
having the first Spaceport in Europe
could be worth 3.8 billion pounds to the
economy over the next decade
[Music]
virgin orbit has successfully launched
satellites on four Rockets from its
California base but that followed a test
flight that failed and the UK's civil
aviation Authority has been cautious in
giving the Spaceport the go-ahead it has
taken months to get the paperwork signed
off the authorities had to check the
blast zone of a fully fueled rocket
blowing up liais with air traffic
control on clearing the skies and
assessed the risk to shipping if
anything falls from the skies
foreign
is looking at illegal fishing human
trafficking and so on another is testing
out the possibility of making really
expensive very difficult to make on
Earth super Alloys and semiconductors
this is the kind of stuff that is now
possible and because the launch costs
are coming down it's much cheaper to
reach space now once this has gone up a
space cornwall's hoping to launch
another rocket in around six months time
and that this will become routine this
race for space is taking on a whole new
dimension